d'identité mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la
secrétaire d'état chargée de la jeunesse
et du service national universel
l'articulation à venir du service
national universel lui et ses nus
dépendent désormais du ministère de
l'éducation nationale et du ministère
des armées avec l' enthousiasme qui vous
caractérise madame la secrétaire d'état
vous incarnerez une nouvelle fois dans
ce gouvernement ce s est venu mais cette
fois en tant que secrétaire d'état
chargée de la jeunesse et du service
national universel
finalement cette configuration illustre
bien l'évolution de la mise en oeuvre
d'une ceni dont l'origine dans la
présidente législature avait été portée
par le ministère des armées avant de
passer sous la tutelle de l'éducation
nationale cette façon de travailler en
transversalité entre deux ministères est
intéressante à plus d'un titre elle le
permis à la fois de déployer avec
davantage de cohérence des leviers
d'insertion sociale et professionnelle
et de renouer avec la citoyenneté avec
ce qui fait natio pour reconstruire un
mieux vivre ensemble cependant à ce
stade d'une nouvelle organisation qui se
met en place d'une nouvelle ambition est
alors que je suis interrogé sur la
montée en puissance du s est nu peu
d'informations ont été communiquées à ce
sujet madame la secrétaire d'état
pouvez-vous partager aujourd'hui avec la
représentation nationale les éléments de
nature à illustrer plus particulièrement
le rôle du ministère des armées dans la
trajectoire du s est tenue dans les
années qui viennent je vous remercie
la parole est à mon âme soeur ali
secrétaire d'état chargée de la jeunesse
et du service national universel
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
mesdames messieurs les députés madame la
députée prieto je vous remercie de poser
cette question parce qu'elle me permet
également de saluer les quarante mille
jeunes qui ont servi et qui ce qu'ils
ont vécu cette expérience absolument
unique quarante mille jeunes qui ont
fait nation
accompagné de plusieurs milliers
d'encadrants madame la députée et qui
ont vécu depuis 2019 ont rejoint cette
grande communauté des volontaires du
service national vers celle pour
atteindre 70 mille jeunes madame la
députée les corps en uniforme
aujourd'hui participe déjà au service
national universel en encadrant bien sûr
un tiers des encadrants viennent soit
des réserves des réservistes soit des
retraités de nos de nos armées il
participe au séjour de cohésion il
participe également à la journée défense
et mémoire ils accueillent nos jeunes
lors des missions d'intérêt général dans
la phase deux avec des préparations
militaires mais également en réalité
avec des missions mémorielle ça vient
compléter l'engagement du monde
associatif ça vient compléter
l'engagement du monde de l'éducation
populaire et de l'éducation nationale et
c'est pour cela que avoir cette double
tutelle être aux côtés du ministre des
armées sébastien lecornu être aux côtés
du ministre de l'éducation nationale et
de la jeunesse pap ndiaye est une chance
pour nos jeunes est ce parce que plus
que jamais madame la députée nous
réunissons l'excellence lé excellence
française autour de nos jeunes c'est
notre priorité est évidemment cette
priorité elle se déploiera pour engager
et accroître la culture de l'engagement
de l'engagement civique et citoyen dont
notre jeunesse a tant besoin oui nous
avons besoin de cohésion nationale oui
nous avons besoin d'eux mixité sociale
où il nous avons besoin d'égalité des
chances et il se trouve que ces trois
excellence le permettent madame la
députée pour répondre très explicitement
à votre question l'école l'armée au delà
des leur partage et au delà du mérite
qu'il permet de transmettre au delà des
valeurs de travail d'efforts de
collectif aujourd'hui nous sommes en
train de faire avec le ministre des
armées et le ministre éducation
nationale l'inventaire l'état des lieux
grâce